고생하셨습니다.
수고하셨습니다.
기억나는 제일 힘들었던 순간인가요?
진짜 마스크 부대라고 표현해도 될지 모르겠는데
저는 코로나19가 다시 온 줄 알았어요.
마스크, 마스크, 마스크, 마스크.
이해가 안 가는 게
마스크 끼고 앉아있는 이유는 뭡니까?
앞줄에 싹 다 마스크를 쓰고 오셔서
이게 무슨 일이지? 그랬는데
앞에서 가까이는 보고 싶은데
얼굴은 나가기 싫은 거예요.
근데 분명히 저는 대화를 해야 되는데
말 걸까 봐 마스크 끼고 있는 거예요?
그거 마스크 아니고 부메랑 맞은 거 같은데?
제가 혹시라도 말 걸면 웃기려고 안 하셔도 돼요.
그냥 솔직히 말해서.
제가 얘기하면 그냥 자기 얘기를 하면 돼요.
안 웃겨도 되거든요?
그냥 얘기하면 돼요.
그래서 이런 생각을 한번 해봤습니다.
진짜 누구나 다 내 얼굴이 나가도 되고
마스크를 안 써도 되고
그리고 너무 즐겁게 내가 말을 걸었을 때도
그냥 대화를 하실 수 있는
분들만 한번 보시면 어떨까?
단 하루만.
노 마스크.
노 마스크 공연이라고 해서
오늘 오신 분들은 다 깨끗하시고 청정하시고
그러고 있을 거면서 왜 오신 거예요?
왜?
가만히.
왜 그러신 거예요?
마스크도 끼지 말라고 했더니
마스크 안 끼고 왜 그러고 있는 거예요?
말을 해야 될 거 아니야, 이 새끼야.
너 이 공연 뭔지 알고 왔을 거 아니야.
무슨 공연인지 알잖아요.
누구랑 왔어요?
혼자 왔어요.
혼자 왔다고?
뭐 하시는 분인데 왜 혼자 왔어요?
직업군입니다.
직업군이?
그래서 뭐 총이 있어?
뭐?
어차피 총 못 갖고 다니잖아.
직업군이면 화면에 나가면 안 되시는 분이잖아요.
이수 지역이라서 상관없어요.
무슨 지역?
이수 지역이라서.
복창 소리 봐라.
요즘 군대 기 빠진 거 봐봐요.
직업군인데 왜 이렇게 혼자 이렇게 오시게 된 거예요?
솔로라서.
솔로라서?
내일이잖아.
솔로라서 왔다는 게 뭔 소리예요?
같이 올 사람이 없어서.
같이 올 사람이 없어서?
아, 근데 별로 이렇게 유쾌하신 분도 아닌데
왜 왔냐 이거예요.
그렇게 돌구처처럼 앉아 있을 거면서.
나 왔는데 다 박수치도 혼자 이러고 있길래
방역판인 줄 알고 총으로 쏠 뻔했어요.
왜 왔냐고.
그러고 있을 거면서.
이제 저 억지로 웃는 거 봐봐.
지금 화면에 잡히니까.
웃지도 않는데 앞자리에 앉아가지고.
열심히 중간 정도 눌렀는데.
그래? 그래서 여기 앞에서 보기 싫어요?
왜냐면 오늘 주제는 너예요.
항상 공연 주제가 있거든요?
오늘은 너예요.
군인, 너, 솔로.
이거 한번 직업 한번 후드 한번 싹 닦아볼게요.
너희들 뭐하는 애들이야?
뭐하는 애들이야?
그냥 회사원이요.
회사원? 친구죠 둘이?
모르는 사이요.
모르는 사이야?
혼자 온 거야?
네.
형 혼자 온 거?
이 C 혼자 온 존이 있어가지고 C 크게 못 웃고
가만히 소리 안 내서 웃는 애들.
이거라면은 공연이 개 X댑니다 이게 C.
혼자 와가지고 크게 웃으면 이상해지니까.
웃겨도.
몇 살이에요?
서른 한 살.
서른 한 살 여기는?
서른 일곱.
되게 젊네?
어떻게 뭐 하시는 분이에요?
회사 다니고 있어요.
회사 다니고 형은?
저도 회사 다니고 있어요.
회사 다니고. 형은?
서른.
회사 다니고 있고 커플이고.
왜? 말고니까 바로 쫄았어.
아니요.
너는 이 정도 앉았으면 내가 말 걸 거라는 예상을 무조건 했잖아.
그죠?
그러니까 둘이 오면서 무슨 얘기 했어?
오빠 말 걸면 어떻게 할 거야?
오빠한테 말 걸 수 있잖아.
그럼 오빠 뭐라고 할 거야?
그러면 또 이제 남자들 대부분이 계속 야 나한테 말 걸면 끝나지.
내가 얼마나 재밌는데.
이상진이 나한테 안 돼.
내가 말면 그냥 죽어.
나가면 뭐 이제 나가잖아.
오빠 왜 얼굴 빨개졌어?
말 못 했어?
내가 말하면 당황할까 봐.
그래 얘기했을 거 아니야.
맞지? 했지? 했지?
내가 말하면 학교에서 이것 좀 쳤는데 그거 한 거 아니야.
했지?
여기 앉으면 무조건 그런 얘기 하면서 온다고.
안 했어?
뭐? 어떤 얘기를 했냐니까?
이 XXX.
마스크 다 써.
마스크 벗겨놨더니 말을 안 하네?
처음 군인부터 잘못됐어. 이거.
군인 또 있어요?
군인 얘기하라고.
어떻게 그게 군인이야.
내가 왔던 사람 말고 군인이 얘기하라고.
그 옆에는 육군 참모총장이에요?
공연 분위기 질이 왜 이래 이거.
이럴 거면 내가 군부대를 내가 위문 공연을 갈 테니까 오지 마.
이거 뭐야 뭐 백발 아저씨가 있어.
어떻게 되는 거야?
어디까지 군인이에요?
그 옆에는?
모르는 사람이에요?
어떻게 가죠? 그 옆에는?
제 와이프입니다.
아 와이프분?
딸이 아니라?
잠깐 봐보세요.
얼굴 가리고 있어서 안 보여. 딸처럼 보여가지고.
내려보세요.
아 와이프네.
모자 한 번 벗어볼 수 있어요? 다 하얗죠 여기.
어떤 군인이세요 형님?
부사관.
어떤 군인이세요?
부사관? 똑같은 부사관?
나이가 어떻게 되세요?
84년생?
형님은 나이가 어떻게 되세요?
너 2년 되면 저렇게 돼.
머리 싹 빠진다.
너 군인이라면 똑같잖아.
2년 전에도 군인 부사관이셨죠?
네.
2년 뒤에 이렇게 되는 거야.
예.
알겠다.
야 저게 잡지 마.
너무 밝아서 그러는데 모자 좀 쓰고 있으면 안 돼요?
눈이 부셔가지고.
선글라스 하나만 주시면 안 돼요?
누나 선글라스 안 쓸 거면 나 주면 안 돼요?
눈이 존나 부셔가지고.
형님.
이제 말을 할 수 있냐.
눈 부셔가지고.
나 이제 형 얼굴 처음 보는 겨.
전쟁 나면 최전방에 있어야겠네.
어머니 이거 비싼 거예요?
비싼 거예요.
비싼 거예요?
네.
닝닝허니가 뭐야?
뭐 하시는 분인데요?
네.
금은빵이에요?
근데 왜 유명해요?
왜 저는 몰라요?
유튜버예요.
유튜버예요?
누구랑 오셨어요?
동생들하고요.
어디 있어요?
저기.
저기 두 명 있고 여기 한 명 있고 셋이?
네.
아.
예?
이거 가지면 누나랑 사귀어야 될까 봐.
내 스타일이 아예 아니여가지고.
선글라스 하나에 팔릴 순 없잖아요.
누나 돈이 아무리 많아도 내 스타일이 아니면 저는 안 만나거든요.
네.
뭐 하시는 분이라고요?
저 닝닝허니랑 크리에이터예요.
아.
크리에이터.
금을.
금 감정하고 있어요.
아.
감정.
금을 많이 갖고 있는 게 아니라.
네.
아.
오늘 누가.
여기는 뭐 하시는 분이에요?
여기요.
여기는 뭐 하시는 분들이세요?
저요?
응.
둘 다.
저.
가만히 있어요.
입술 위에 파리예요?
아니 6시 공연까지 해야 되는데 계속 날아다닌단 말이에요.
가만히 있어요.
뭐 하시는 분이에요?
저는 저 언니 피부관리 하고 있어요.
아.
피부관리 샵을 하시는 거고.
누나는.
저는 친구고요.
네.
저도 sns에서.
아.
크리에이터야.
누나는 피부 안가요?
네.
그럼 피부관리 샵면 여기 점에 대해서 얘기를 해주고 왔어요?
점은 안 빼요.
점은 안 빼요?
저도 여기 점이 있거든요.
아.
이거 왜 안 빼요?
복점이에요.
저는 복점인데 누나는 복점 아니지 않아요?
저 복점이에요.
복점이에요?
무슨 복점이에요?
어.
재물 나가는 거를 막아준다고.
네.
김남주 씨도 이 자리에 있다면 절대 빼지 말라고 하는 분이에요.
아.
재물 나가는 거를 막아주는 점이래요.
그래서 외모를 포기하고 재물을 막고 있는 거예요?
그렇죠.
재물이 막아주던가요?
네.
그 점을 책임질게요.
제 거에 붙일게요.
내가 너를 책임질 거예요.
네.
내가 너를 책임지는 거 보다 그 점을 책임질게요.
그 점을 그대로 있는 그대로 뽑아주면 뭐 여기다 붙일까요?
아니면 여기 사타구니에다 붙일까요?
여기다 붙일까요?
섹시하게.
엉덩이 뒤에 가운데다 여기다 붙일까요?
뽑아주시면 제가 어디 간 거 붙일 거예요.
근데 이 점이.
점이라는 거는 이 깊이가 있어요.
심이.
알죠?
그래서 점을 한 번 빼가지고 없어지는 게 있고 두 번 세 번 해야 빼지는
게 있어요.
그래서 이렇게 깊이가 있어가지고 어느 정도까지 들어가 있는지 몰라서
레이저를 한 번 뒤지고 두 번 뒤지고 세 번 뒤지고.
계속 뒤져야 돼요.
근데 누나 점은 지금 보니까 그거 빼잖아.
그럼 아마 여기 관통할 거야.
그래서 계속 빛이 샐 거야 얼굴에.
얼굴에 빛이 나요.
점 뺐는데 이렇게 관통하고 있어요.
그거 어떻게 된 거야?
점심이.
친구 얘기하는데 그렇게.
공감하고 있었던 거야?
예?
알겠어.
필라테스 하시는 분 있어요?
필라테스 강사?
없어요?
필라테스 강사님.
필라테스 배운다.
마스크 문제가 아니네.
성향 문제네.
얼굴만 내놓고 있으면 뭐 하죠.
대화를 하자고.
나는 운동을 한다.
형님 용기 내서.
어떤 운동을 하세요?
저는 요즘에 마라톤 합니다.
마라톤?
얼마나 뛰세요?
풀 마라톤 한 번 뛰어봤습니다.
풀 마라톤.
그냥 러닝을 하다가 이제 마라톤까지 하는 거고.
그냥 한 번 도전해봤어요.
한 번 도전해봤어요?
마라톤 42.7km를 딱 뛰면 런어사이라는 게 느껴지나요?
죽을 것 같은데.
런어사이라는 게 있다면서요.
제가 안 떠봤는데.
런어사이가 너무 기분이 좋다는데 그게 뭐예요?
안 느껴져요.
런어사이가 느껴져서 기분이 좋은 게 있어서 뛴다고 하는데 그게 안 느껴진다고요?
운동 런닝화나 옷을 팔기 위한 마케팅적인 거짓말이에요.
그렇게 얘기를 해서 영상이 나오면 많은 나이키나 뉴발란스가 형한테 소송을 걸 수가 있어요.
그걸 다 이겨낼 만큼 부자신가요?
말을 실수할 때가 있어요.
맞아요.
런어사이를 느끼고 싶어서 런닝하시는 분들을 위해서 한 마디 해주실 수 있다면?
제가 전문가는 아닌데 제가 한 번 풀 마라톤을 뛰어보니까 일단 꾸준한 건 좋은 것 같아요.
풀 마라톤을 하기 위해서 제가 한 6개월 동안 꾸준한 네온을 하고 있어요.
제 모습이 좋았던 거지 런어사이는 없어요.
그럼 형은 뭐 할 때 제일 기분이 좋나요?
제가 조그마한 사업을 하는데 그 사업에 프로젝트가 수주될 때 제일 좋아요.
어떤 사업을 하는지 물어봐도 되나요?
인테리어 회사를 하고 있다고 보시면 돼요.
인테리어를 그렇게 잘 아시고 안목을 있으신 분이 와이프는 왜 이렇게 선택하신 거예요?
제가 제 인생 최고의 선택입니다.
아.
제 인생의 최고의 선택.
지금 또 말실수를 또 하셨어요.
하여튼 멋있는 분입니다.
오늘은 또 엄마랑 오신 분 있어요?
누구랑 왔어요? 아들이랑? 아들이랑 엄마랑?
누가 가자고 했어요?
엄마가? 아들 몇 살이에요?
22살? 엄마가 왜 아들이랑 같이 왔어요?
왜 아들을 보여주고 싶었어요?
어떤 쇼츄 제일 재밌게 봤어요?
형님은 뭐 하시는 분인데요?
일본 순정만화처럼 하고 왔어요.
두 번째 줄 형님. 형님이에요? 누나예요? 뭐야?
너 뭐야 이거? 뭐예요? 순정만화예요? 뭐예요?
팬텀이요? 가면 쓰고 온 거야? 뭐야 이거?
뭐야 이거? 반인?
부끄러워요.
부끄러워요? 너 나 좋아해?
여기 누구랑 왔어요?
저 혼자요.
혼자? 알겠어요. 인스타 팔로우 몇 명이요?
선배님이요.
뭐 하시는 분이에요? 뭐 하는 사람?
대학생이요.
대학생? 어디 대학교 학생?
그럼 지금 대구에서 온 거예요?
대구에서 아저씨 보러 온 거야?
근데 왜 혼자 왔어요?
야 그 팔로우 300명 산 거야?
아이 씨 팔로우 300명이면 친구 존나 많은 거야?
여자한테는 욕을 못하니까 일단 이렇게 할게.
미안해 너한테 한 거 아니야. 얘한테 한 거야. 어?
팔로우 300명 있다면 왜 친구가 없어?
군인 너 안 웃을 거면 나가면 안 되냐?
존나 걸려져서 다 웃고 있는데.
개 전투 아니야? 땀을 왜 닦고 네가?
뭐야 너?
상사가 차려 부동산에서 시켜 먹고 나갔어?
뭐 하는 거야? 어?
남자애도 군인이고 좀 근육이 있어 보이잖아.
얼굴 왜 이렇게 빨개졌어?
군대 다녀왔어요?
네 다녀왔어요.
어디 갔다 왔어요?
김해.
김해?
그거 뭐 하는데?
거기서 뭐 했어? 육군?
공병.
공병?
네.
너 분리수거해?
공병이 왜 나와?
나 종이류.
공병이래.
야 이 XX야 이거.
진짜 웃을 때 소리를 낸 적이 있어요?
태어나서? 오늘 말고?
오늘이 가장 웃긴 거 같아요.
오늘이 가장 웃겨요?
어디서 왔다고? 과천?
파주에서.
파주에서?
그냥 파주면은 북한 가깝지 않아?
용기 내서 넘어가면 안 되냐?
그쪽이 다 잘 맞는 거 같아.
넘어가. 용기 내. 그쪽으로.
야 여기 오는 거보다 그쪽 넘어가는 게 약간 빠르지 않아? 거리상으로?
어?
아 넘어가.
어떤 거 공부하고 계세요?
저 심리학과.
심리학과? 지금 아저씨 심리가 지금 어떤 거 같아요? 힘들어 보여. 그러니까 그 힘들어 보이고 나도 힘들어. 누구 때문에 힘든 거 같다. 군인이지?
이제 나가면서 여자친구한테 하죠. 봤지? 나가지고 계속 웃기는 거야.
내가 딱 그 템포를 안다고. 내가 아무 말 안 하고 받아줘야 그 사람이 계속 웃길 수 있어. 내가 딱 해주는 거잖아. 봤지? 내 실력.
내가 딱 해줘면 딱 죽지. 여자분은 뭐 하시는 분이세요?
어떤 회사.
아 같은 회사에서 만난 거예요?
네.
아 근데 요즘 보통 회사가 사내 연애는 금지되어 있지 않아요?
제가 퇴사하면서 만났어요.
아 퇴사할 정도로 마음에 들어서. 마음에 들어서 퇴사할 테니 얘를 만나겠다 이거예요? 아니면은 퇴사한 김에 이 회사에서 남은 건 또 없는데.
저한테 고백이나 해볼까? 그랬더니 걸려든 거예요.
그러면 이전에 퇴사하고 나서 그 전 회사에서 이제 사귀는 거 다 알고? 몰라요?
몇몇 번 안 해요.
몇몇 번 안 해요? 근데 이게 만약에 유튜브로 나가면 이제 다 알게 되잖아요. 어때요?
아 그래요? 갑자기 직장 상사가 전화와서 야 걔 나랑도 사귀고 있어. 근데 이 정도로 엉겨붙을 거면 끝나고 오늘 모텔 가는 거예요? 넘어가 있어요 지금. 엄마 뭐 아들이랑 보기 좀 민망해?
아들도 그러고 이거 알 건 알아야 돼.
아들 태어나서 모텔 몇 번 가봤어? 모쏠이면 뭐 모텔 안 가요? 혼자 들어갈 수 있지? 모텔이 꼭 누구랑 같이 가요? 남자랑도 가고 어디 여행 가면 숙박하러 가고 그러는 거지.
이상형이 뭐야? 몇 년생이야? 05? 누나 돼? 누나 돼? 나이 많은 사람 돼? 근데 너 어디 살아? 서울 살아? 서울 안 살아도 돼? 엄마가 하지마. 엄마 만날 거예요?
근데 너 한 번도 안 사귀어 봤는데 따지는 게 많아. 근데 아직 어디 사는지는 몰라. 물어볼게. 어디 살아요?
네? 목동, 서울, 서울이야. 어떻게 오셨어요? 아, 자주 오시는 분이구나.
처음 왔어요? 누구랑 왔어요? 옆에 뭐예요? 그림쟁이는. 옆에 그림쟁이는 뭐예요? 스케치북하고 같이 왔어요?
조만간 이제 얼굴에 그리겠는...
아니요 처음 왔어요. 처음 왔어요? 누구랑 왔어요? 옆에 뭐예요 그림쟁이는? 옆에 그림쟁이는 뭐예요? 스케치북하고 같이 왔어요? 조만간 이제 얼굴에 그리겠는...
공백이 거기 밖에 없어가지고
뭐하시는 분들이에요?
니가 색칠공부 옆에 한거야?
아니면 지 혼자 어디서 해온거야?
누나가 했어요?
누나가 타투이스트야?
그럼
혼자 이렇게 자기 목에다가
이렇게 했다고?
형님은 뭐하시는 분이에요?
아
주소를 다 써놓은거에요 잊어버릴까봐
하도 실수로 해가지고
매칭매칭 이거 다 써놓은거야
아 그 택배가는
맨날 다니는 그 주소에요?
그 프리즌브레이크처럼 지도 그려놓은거에요?
근데 그
앞에 옆에 앉은
남자분은
이거 나 아니야?
족불경험 안 낫는거 같은데
존댔네?
왜 온거야? 나 너 죽일라고 왔냐?
야 둘 중에 한 명 뒤지는거 아니냐고
야 너 나 아니야?
뭐야
야 씨 너 나야?
이 새끼 X같이 생겼네
누구나 왔어
이 X
와 이제 웃네 군인 나오니까
이게 진짜 웃긴거야
오늘 내가 다 했다
군대 있을 때 별명이 이상준이었어요?
항상 듣고 있습니다
그쵸 듣고 있죠
그래서 온거에요 저 닮았던 소리 들어서?
야 너 닮았으니까
너 옆에 그
누나가 나한테 말 안 걸었으면
너 다음에 또 오려고 했어
내가 잡아낼 때까지
다음에 한번
특집으로 다 모아놓고 한번 해봐야겠다
족불경험 모아놓고